hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play mari oh I'm
still trying to find my files so in the
meantime I had this little game here
that I was interested in playing so you
can get hats that's cool right just get
kind of hat let's get more red and then
more more black yeah that's good yeah
red and blue
yeah no purple no pink no pink and pink
yeah yeah so basically if you haven't
guessed it's okay pink and then a
slightly darker pink it's it's Mario the
original Mario with
I don't know how it might actually just
be like a [ __ ] right take two yeah
yeah
so if you guys want to have some fun
this game all four player co-op in it it
also has like a bunch of different stuff
there's different like this map packs
there's portal Maps
yeah Sonia I'll leave a lot of the game
up to you guys this is just a taste you
obviously don't want to see a full
playthrough of Mario but this is the fun
game for you to find in your own in the
description